situada a 300 km al oeste de abiyán la
región de nagua es una de las mayores
zonas agrícolas de costa de marfil
también uno de los territorios más
afectados por el trabajo infantil hoy
xavi tiene 18 años nunca fue a la
escuela porque su abuela la cuidaba en
el campo cuando nuestros amigos iban a
la escuela ella quería que fuéramos pero
no podía permitírselo así que no tuvo
más remedio que enviarnos al campo al
igual que xavi el 90% de los casos de
trabajo infantil se producen en el seno
de la familia y suelen suponer el
abandono de la escuela pero en este
centro dedicado a la acogida de niños
víctimas de la trata o del trabajo
forzado también hay muchos niños de
países vecinos fatal un chico de 15 años
de burkina faso fue recogido en un campo
de cacao hace una semana
fatal o no es víctima del trabajo
forzado sino de la trata de personas
desde burkina una red organizada lo
llevó a costa de marfil
los burkineses los malienses cuando
tienen un hijo en costa de marfil para
ellos es algo seguro así que todo el
mundo quiere tener un hijo aquí con un
producto como el cacao que atrae a todo
el mundo
así como el cacao representa el 14 por
ciento del producto interno bruto de
costa de marfil es la actividad más
afectada por el trabajo infantil en el
país por lo tanto es en las aldeas de
los plantadores donde tratan de
concientizar a los adultos esta brigada
contra el trabajo infantil viene a
reunirse con el jefe del pueblo para
transmitir un mensaje sencillo al
dirigirse a los líderes de la comunidad
la brigada espera a llegar a todo el
pueblo
pueden ser nuestros reemplazos el jefe
está ahí él también tiene reuniones voy
a hablar con los que pueden ser reacios
para mostrarles los beneficios otro
lugar según las últimas estimaciones
para 2019 15 millones de menores
trabajaban en el sector del cacao en
costa de marfil y ghana